Oh welcome to fat man I'm Batman I'm
Kevin Smith and I'm Marc Bernard holy
[ __ ] we are live once again as always
from the scum and villainy Cantina right
here on Hollywood Boulevard in Hollywood
California put your hands together to
the folks at home no you are not
fictional
I I'm wearing a few minutes late because
I was home bunch in the runaways part
five it's good [ __ ] show man
they finally spoilers they finally used
of some of their powers like all
together at once there's a shot at the
beginning of every episode that shows
them all together and like kind of like
the group shot like the Avengers turn
around chunk of that show and I was like
when's that gonna have it and it
happened in Episode five it was pretty
awesome man are you current I am almost
grown I didn't watch today's but I'm
almost caught up uh charming is [ __ ]
no it really is it really is and my kid
my 13 year old son who will not watch
anything that I tell him to watch cuz he
doesn't think I'm cool right which is
fair cuz I'm not but he was like uh hey
buddy want to watch stranger things I
hear it's cool knows [ __ ] and then
you put on side Kollek dad this is
awesome well watch the waterways I don't
think so sounds like [ __ ] and now I
would say dad when's the next runaways I
want to watch more runaways it's the
thing that you could share yeah he's
like this is the one thing I'm not
ashamed about you for yeah you have this
much taste
all right speaking of shame I [ __ ] I
spent the morning bawling in tears
because I watched all of crisis on Earth
X the CW crossover event so I I did it
all in one sit down and oh my god it was
it was [ __ ] it looked expensive all I
could think about is like having done a
few of those shows the scheduling
nightmare of getting everybody together
on-screen and they did lots of scenes
where they were like
look at all these [ __ ] heroes you
fox-like just really showing off the
whole cast and working together and
crossing over and stuff but incredibly
emotional like especially considering
like you know is there fighting a planet
Nazi and which is like this makes for a
great comic book show and and it you
know wow what a great reason to
interrupt Barry and irises wedding and
stuff what a great reason to bring a lot
of characters together and then bust
them out but they took the [ __ ] story
in legit directions that change the
shape of all the shows going forward
yeah and more than that they were
fighting Nazis
yeah and for real [ __ ] Nazis not like
kid Nazis not like science fiction Nazis
yeah ha ha world he was called Hilter no
like it was flat-out they said Hitler
times days like what's that pink
triangle for it's like oh well let me
tell you what this is about like it was
we're not [ __ ] holding anything back
Nazis
it was beautiful and then spoilers if
you haven't seen it yet cover years
because we were talking about some [ __ ]
they killed off professor Stein
yeah oh sorry I told you to [ __ ]
cover your ears they did like I thought
I mean you know it's it's kinda it's a
big bold move at that point he's been
with the show since like I think gone
back to arrow but definitely flash yeah
I think that he he was leaving the show
he's going back to Broadway because
Victor Garber is a for real [ __ ]
thespian yeah you guys but Broadway is
calling and also that show -
particularly he's on Legends that's a
show that's got like 96 main characters
so I imagine the shooting is gruelling
on a show like that yeah but yeah I was
sad to see him go and I like I was
shocked and how [ __ ] moved I was by
the death scene but my only note of like
you know like I understand him and Jax
had the connection as firestorm and so
he gets to die on the Waverider you know
in the operating room and with with his
better half and they had this beautiful
[ __ ] monologue about like your
like my son you've said I was like your
dad I'm like you know and they they have
this relationship so then in the Dana
Marv the story you know they're there at
his funeral and they're burying him and
stuff and you know as he gets up there
and he's like his wife asked his family
asked me to speak and stuff and so he
talks about you know the connection that
they had but then he like breaks down
and then Glick goes over to the mom and
the daughter and starts like talking
about like I should have done more and I
was sitting there watching it going like
don't make it about you like at the end
of Schindler's List like [ __ ] you
couldn't have done any more than you
[ __ ] did and it was weird it took away
from the family more that's the only
thing I would have done different it's
like I know his wife wasn't a main
character on the show but he had a
[ __ ] wife and they were like the
heroes were all there and like we
[ __ ] lost professor Stein and at the
end they were like oh his wife's here
too so it was it was the only note that
was kind of weird but all of it was just
[ __ ] beautiful
they found a way to even soften Oliver
Queen who on TV is just like hard as a
rock gave him a bit of an emotional beat
with felicity and then let them get
married in the last like [ __ ] 10
seconds of the whole event well it's
easy to make him softer when you
actually give like furor Oliver Queen on
this state to the same time it's good
that's a good one he's still the same
[ __ ] hard-ass but he's not I'm not
see what else did I really like in it I
thought it was a really cool idea that
like you know it's the evil Supergirl
needed a heart and they're like let's
just take it from [ __ ] that Supergirl
and they did say though that like
they're 52 you know they go by the DC
the new 52 there's 52 different earths
and stuff this weather was earth x1 they
left out of the books because they're
like it's just so evil but they said at
one point like there's a Supergirl on 52
earths which means that like in their
continuity Supergirl is on a different
earth already than flash and arrow so
right does that mean they can introduce
a super girl on earth prime or you know
theoretically yeah would they
oh why but they could let me do whatever
they want sooner or later I think the
like the next crossover event would
probably be crisis on Infinite Earths so
they can collapse at least those two
universes into one universe but I was
shocked at how moving the [ __ ] Nazi
one was not because they were not to
East but because like hey they were
beatin Nazis not as always fun to see
them punch Nazis and they could kill him
too like they were heroes were killing
at one point Oliver Queen like you know
didn't have his [ __ ] bow and arrow so
he's like [ __ ] it and he was like
spraying bullets and I'm like you would
never go back after that dude like like
look at the maximum carnage instead of
[ __ ] one - which and I agree like
you're real good at it but pick up a
[ __ ] gun like so it was it was a
wonderful event I I enjoyed the whole
[ __ ] thing eating sitting down eating
it in one full swoop and it was it just
looked like one big movie and they
played it like that as well I
appreciated that more than than the last
crossover which felt like distinct
episodes of those shows that kind of had
some webbing that tie them together
yes give me one big for our story I
agree and Supergirl last season it was
just the tail end of her show they're
like hey man come to this other earth
right like in the coda but they had each
one carried a full-up so there's a
really nice moment where you know they
do that on those shows all the time nice
nice callbacks where she they called the
other Supergirl like Oliver and her were
a couple on earth not see on Earth X and
so she was a general so that allowed and
you know they said it the whole [ __ ]
series and of the three episodes leading
up to the moment and I fancy myself a
writer and I fancy myself clever
sometimes where you know I could see
[ __ ] coming like you know I didn't see
the sixth sense coming I'll give you
that but who [ __ ] did you know so
like this I should have saw coming but
when they kept calling her general in
general and they always kind of borrow
from the Superman mythos they're setting
themselves up perfectly for the moment
where Melissa goes to fight you know
herself Supergirl goes to fight
Supergirl from Earth X and she's outside
the ship and she goes general would you
care to step outside like a direct lift
and I was I was alone
at 4:30 in the morning watching this
amount as blaze dawn my wife came
running down like what happened I was
like [ __ ] Supergirl jizz she goes I
don't give a [ __ ] and turn right so it
was really really really wonderful what
else you been up to I went up to Hearst
Castle over the weekend for my sort of
belated birthday la-dee-da Oh Hearst
Castle
I have long time ago I got dragged there
to pray I like imagining it as like what
if Bruce Wayne just was rich and didn't
actually fight crime this is what he
would have done true and I found myself
having to explain [ __ ] about like
Citizen Kane to my wife but not in the
presence of the kids again now the
movies about a guy you had a sled sleds
named rosebud rosebud fYI is named after
Marion Davies is clitoris which we've
been hearing about the entire [ __ ]
time they tell you that unlit no I'm
trying not to tell my wife that in front
of the children
why did you read it in the literature
someone I know this because then it must
have been hard not to share it like
you're the only one that's gonna share
because they're all Marion Davies oh
look it's William Randolph Hearst in my
name Davey's his longtime paramour I'm
like oh honey that never mind
yeah it's awesome I'll tell you later
but it's awesome did you tell you tell
her later on yeah you guys were alone
yeah was it like for plague you guys
have married a while so even the mention
of like a man rosebud also I'm not
filthy rich so no it's beautiful that a
state yeah I read somewhere recently
that or was it yeah somewhere I [ __ ]
read somewhere online you know Chris
Hardwick the Nerdist his lovely wife is
part of the Hearst family yeah the great
grand daughter or granddaughter
I believe she's Patty Hearst daughter so
yeah great great granddaughter of
William Randolph Hearst aka the you know
the real-life citizen King Charles
Foster Kane so I think that like he can
go up there and like take a shower
[ __ ] up you would be walking around
the tour and you'd be like hey how enjoy
your burrito and he's just gonna to raid
the [ __ ] fridge cuz like he lives
there that it's kind of cool this is all
mine
you can all leave yeah that's the power
of a podcast where's our mansion if you
will never this is our mansion right
here man the scum and villainy cantina I
love coming here home away from home
alright man so we right before we went
JC was saying hey some people want to
get some [ __ ] sign I said oh just have
them throw it up on a bar some people
bring like pops or whatever but I
believe somebody threw up their passport
which I will happily [ __ ] sign then I
guess I can't whose is it it's yours you
have to so it's a dead Passport
so but this is not legit anymore oh it
is legit
so don't personalize it as well what's
your name what's your name CH r i st and
listen a brother can always use another
passport man Chris wait after the a what
happens don't [ __ ] look at me like
you ought to know how to spell this
that's a lot of [ __ ] letters man oh
wait so is it Krista Krista Ferrari
what's 4r your whole name is Christopher
ari OC your first name is Krista
generally I don't sign if everybody's
[ __ ] all their names I pick one and
[ __ ] like it's so weird Krista is
good righty though Krista [ __ ] I can't
get into sister Alexandria Ferrari she's
gonna [ __ ] steal the Pink Panther
diamond after this
I wrote Krista travel with an
exclamation point is that work or should
I write more it you're welcome to you
had a seizure you were the girl that had
the seizure at The Improv oh my god so
we had a show at The Improv uh Hollywood
babble-on well I got let me explain to
everybody else we're not the only ones
here we had a show at The Improv a long
time this is going back right and in the
middle of the show Krista here had a
seizure and we thought we were really
funny but that wasn't it at all and and
they thank you and then they they got
you out of there you were there as well
I mean you were a hero we were the ones
going what do we do
like we froze up on stage but we then
they came and took her away so Wow while
you were going through the seizure you
were like I still have to listen to this
[ __ ] podcast [ __ ] insult to injury
so wait you feel like you felt like you
died your heart stopped at that Club I'm
totally changing the marketing
heart-stoppingly good show
wow man alright so holy [ __ ] was the
lighting travel was so [ __ ] is this your
passport back to the land of the living
past back to the living hmm no just to
say thank you so I can keep going on in
using my passport in general huh
number one great to see you again here's
the best but don't forget that you'll
need that and number two hey [ __ ]
what was it like on the other side you
feel like you went to the other side no
well I did until you [ __ ] said it
like that alright hold on hold on here
we go man so my mom took one to the
other side she told me what she thought
it was like let me see if it's anything
like what you saw okay so I stood up and
I went towards the door and then all of
a sudden I did turn black and the force
pressure was going up and then stars
were coming down like the star wars star
cept like long start no that's Star Trek
okay and then I was being lifted on my
body boom I went out and then lift it up
and 360 no hunger no anything just like
unconditional love life passed before my
eyes like in a wheel of fortune dirt
dirt dirt dirt dirt type thing landed on
the last thing the guy was like huh I
thought he did something yeah I know
and then like seven people line up there
like hey how are you oh my gosh I was so
happy so loved it was amazing and then
this guy comes up and he's like that it
uh and it goes now your time and there
was like okay open their hands put their
hands together and then it closed them
I'm so right now this is [ __ ]
terrifying wait we'll wait slow down
this is too much information wait down
this hall exactly like I can't even I
don't think I'm allowed to tell
everything for some reason like and
they're all bitter bad experience it was
depressing I was depressed for four
months after and I was also happy that I
knew how to keep my body from failing
like the new actor well not new but from
true True Blood not
take up too much time that he died from
going off alcohol you're talking about
previously over here and that's what
happened to me like I thought okay just
quit you can't you gotta really like
can't even do that like it's really
dangerous so yeah it was great so if I
had benzos I would have it was great
when I came back I was really angry
because I felt my body again I like you
know I pulled out my hands I looked at
my but I was like this is a shell that I
have to live with and through and
usually you're mad that you came back
you would have rather I want to go home
I called it I want to stay wherever that
was you want to merge with I'm not
allowed to go back for some reason I
don't know honey I'm not allowed to go
back like I'm not even afraid to die
like let me die like even if I stood at
the cliffs I'm gonna be like boom and
knocked me over the other way like a
perv because I can't like maybe I can
get injured so Flatliners is [ __ ] is
what you're saying
yeah well look for you look it up online
they have five come back like come back
like five times in a row and they're
like Oh God God God I don't know if it's
God but I know that it was something
that was definitely connected to the
earth I saw a bunch of grass and
butterflies and flowers and a big huge
lake behind and Sun and trees and just
everything was great it will kind of
grass what kind of green green a green
green grass no dead grass long green
grass but not too long to where there
are snakes in it or anything no nothing
yaowang or evil trying to pull you into
a dark place no I saw pets what's that
it sounds like Amsterdam and instead am
notre no suit this place is more like
the mountains up very far in the
mountains even up on highway two you
could probably find it on the west Bork
made those like Elysium fields all
written down
it's better it's better there's no there
is no comparison to this place I don't
even want to talk about superheroes no
more man I just write a book if this
actually is resonating with you I'll
just write a book on it do that write a
book on it all right give it up for the
doctor talk to you thank you well done
Christopher ro [ __ ] man everything's
gonna seem trivial bullish point well
anyway on with the notice what happened
in Hollywood well I watched I finished
the Punisher oh did you yeah that'll
cheer us up yeah it's a good time really
it is it's like a party it's like a
birthday party for an eight-year-old
child it was insanely well made it
really was and by the time you get to
the end of it yes it is still three
episodes too long as all these things
seem to be okay but it's actually kind
of beautiful like it's it's very much
about loss it's very much about pain
it's very much about Frank Castle being
a crucible for himself and for everybody
else and and having to burn away
everything that's left of him to find
out what's what remains after that
mm-hmm and it's kind of hopeful by the
time we get to the end really yeah and
you get to meet jigsaw by the time you
get to the end really yeah just kind of
[ __ ] bad-ass
and sorry do you see an Origin or yeah
you've been watching the origin the
entire time really really do you want me
to spoil it for you it's that
good-looking guys it's a good-looking
guy yeah yeah Billy Russo Wow I like tan
who's really good yeah and watching his
face gets shredded is kind of lovely no
I mean that it the show earns every step
that it takes and by the time I get to
the end it especially on the heels of
some of the other Marvel stuff we've
seen this is a show that knows where it
is and knows what it needs to deliver
and knows what you want out of a main
character it's yeah it gets there what
Dolph Lundgren and Lou Gossett jr. can
rest happily knowing that the mantle has
been carried
forward what what where's the character
left leg is there season two forthcoming
and yeah but I think he'd going you
could but I think every season is going
to be like the one last job for Frank
Castle because he seems kind of content
at the end of this show but yeah next
season I'm sure will be we killed Mike
Rose family does Mike Rowe make it to
the end yeah
does Mike Rowe gain weight nope my
favorite thing about him in the comics
news factor I could identify with micro
cast a [ __ ] thin guy I'm like I'm
lost I got nobody
right on alright so I will finish the
punter she said it's worth it yeah I
mean look I was digging it but like you
know took an emotional toll kind of show
that like you [ __ ] stop watching call
your mother and be like I'm so [ __ ]
sorry go hug your wife and protect your
kid [ __ ] like that but I'll check that
out the rest of it yeah there was a
trailer the dropped over the last couple
of days Batman ninja yes [ __ ] yeah I did
the show is called fat man I'm Batman so
whenever something Batman related pops
up my ears to the ground and I saw that
trailer early the day that it Warner
Brothers Japan put it up with no
subtitles or anything there's just this
gorgeous anime looking take on Batman
where Batman's fighting the Joker on the
rooftop and Gotham and somebody explodes
a bomb or something and suddenly he's in
feudal Japan and his entire world is
represented in a few of Japan so you
have Harley Quinn from back then and
Batman is dressed like a I thought a
samurai but it's called Batman ninja or
Ninja Batman Batman : ninja but like
he's got samurai yeah [ __ ] armor
ninjas didn't wear armor it looks
fantastic and the Joker's got an army
and it's representing his armor and then
the very end of the piece they indicate
a giant [ __ ] robot Joker which I was
like holy where did this [ __ ] come
from and apparently they there everyone
involved is a legendary name in the
field of anime and this is one of the
first times that Warner Brothers like
hey man go nuts do what you want so
they're releasing that here with an
American voiceover track or like a
edition so you subtitled so you could
just read the whole thing but it looks
astounding not even just like oh my god
look at the attention to detail and how
cool it is seeing Batman dressed like a
samurai but it like in terms of just
animation alone like it looks like a
cure a good yeah insanely good and also
just like that's an original take like
I've never seen that before what was the
name there was there was a DVD that got
released no he said like 10 years ago
was it like Batman Gotham Knights yes
yes where it was like 10 different
little ones a story that we're taking
place between Batman Begins and the
darkness yeah but like half of those I
feel we're also Japanese in origin not
all of them someone that computer
animated very true but it reminded me a
lot of that just let's let these guys
[ __ ] roll with it like what are they
gonna do you can be amazing and it's
also like I'm sure it'll sell in its
country of origin that's where they were
promoting it but you know it's gonna
[ __ ] move here like that you give us
a representation to Batman that looks
like [ __ ] badass
I don't care if you're not an anime fan
or not it's something that people watch
it look fat it looks fantastic and you
know it comes at the right time for some
people were like Justice League wasn't
my [ __ ] Batman well here you go
nobody could argue with this Batman he's
pretty amazing you know Christopher
Nolan seems to have figured out why
Warner Brothers DC is floundering really
yeah it's not a asked him and somebody
asked on the record he's like because
I'm not doing it pretty much according
to the the conversation at the British
Academy of Film and Television Arts in
London okay the problem is DC not giving
filmmakers the time they need to be
creative that's a privilege and a luxury
that filmmakers don't afford it anymore
I think it was the last time that
anybody was able to say to studio I
might do another one but it will be four
years is what Nolan said to Warner
Brothers when he went from oh is that my
eggs they want one of these a year and
so you know the production line has sped
up and whereas I had a bunch of time to
come up with Batman movies luxury and I
can go do other [ __ ] between them there
they're pumping these [ __ ] out like a
puppy
and so there's some rumor some are gonna
be broken along the way some we're gonna
have hip dysplasia by the time they're
three yes hey I had a [ __ ] lab man I
know what I'm talking about but yeah
like he had seven years between Batman
Begins and the Dark Knight Rises for
those movies and in the five years since
Dark Knight Rises DC's released five
movies and so his point is if you give
them more time they'll make better
movies sure absolutely but I think the
idea is they're like look right now
superhero movies earned even the ones
that we make that nobody seems to care
that much better like that much have
made tremendous amounts of money Suicide
Squad a Batman V Superman Justice League
notwithstanding or something like that
so of course it behooves them as a
studio they're like how do you think we
keep the [ __ ] lights on you know back
when it was westerns we did nothing but
westerns so now we're in this business
as well we're gonna do this for a while
you know III you're never gonna get them
to slow down even with what happened you
know I'm not like what happened was a
train wreck but even with Justice League
you'd imagine that'd be a moment to pump
the brakes and hey let's decide going
forward if we even need a connected
universe or if we just Warner Brothers
this [ __ ] and just let people make
movies that standalone and blah blah
blah and everybody has a different take
on these characters but that'll never
happen again
not as long as you can make money off
these things and remember this was a
company that like what a couple years
ago is like here's our ambitious slate
of 183 movies and here are all the dates
including cyborg 3 you know it'll be a
long time before we see cyborg 1 I think
so I I don't see them slowing down I
think if anything they moved to the yet
they pivot to we're gonna make we're
gonna have them be disconnected and
we're gonna have people make their own
versions of these characters but we
still got to keep to one a year I would
do two like think about I mean I guess
he's right nobody was like we want a
Batman a year from you but it's a
sustainable character with a wealth of
creators why why can't you commit to a
Batman a year just give him more
development time back it up by [ __ ]
two years if you think that's the key
that's the secret to the whole thing I
don't know if that's necessarily the
case to be honest with you like having
more time yeah I mean I think like the
Iron Man how about this just don't do
that
don't make those kinds of movies I like
make movies that people like that was
fun and [ __ ] like that like there was
there was time between Iron Man 1 and
Iron Man 2 and post Iron Man 2 they knew
they were going hard like Iron Man 2
comes and then it's Thor cap the First
Avenger
then it's [ __ ] Avengers and then
you're rolling but they gave themselves
a little bit of time to build the Marvel
did to build the train tracks to
understand that okay we build these
tracks right we can just get the train
rolling in as long as we keep putting
tracks in front of train we're okay
DC has never to date built those tracks
and so it feels as well but but they
have built tracks just not for a
connected universe like one could argue
they built the tracks in the 70s the
Superman they invented the superhero
modern-day superhero movie then
reinvented it in the late eighties early
nineties with Tim Burton and Batman [ __ ]
so they it's not like they're like we're
new to the hero business what they're
new to is the idea of like oh all this
[ __ ] has to make sense now [ __ ] you know
like cuz yet some movies where Batman
was like you killed my parents and
you're like he would never use a gun
though like oh he wouldn't [ __ ] alright
how about this the next movie starts
with him [ __ ] his mortal enemy gets
thrown in the sewer but his parents as a
baby is that better people like I don't
think so and then they changed it up
like hey now he's you know [ __ ] over
the top with Jim Carrey and people like
we kind of like it and then they're like
nipples and Robin people like [ __ ] you
so they've been all over the map and
[ __ ] like that like it's there they're
completely familiar with superhero
movies and they've redefined it a couple
times but it's just the idea of
connecting them seems to be the the
hurdle for them right like it's weird
it's weird watching somebody who knows
what to do and again we always personify
the studio as one person but the people
that were there during the Chris Nolan
era aren't necessarily there like sook
role and marketing I think she's still
there but like Jeff robinov he was the
the Chris Nolan guy ain't there anymore
it's like Kevin taja are so he can't be
like they've lost their way like the
people who are working on these movies
now they weren't working on the comic
book movies that helped define the
studio and that hero so you know I I to
me it's weird watching them fumble with
extended universe it's you know it's
like just take the cuffs off yourself
just go back to what you know best which
is we're gonna make a trilogy in movies
with this filmmaker and if this works
like seems like what they're doing with
Wonder Woman right now like the idea
like they'll have patty Jenkins keep
coming back as long as she wants to and
definitely make at least three of those
before they think a rebooting or
something like that so maybe that's
their lot like instead of trying to be
something they clearly have a problem
being the Marvel Universe just do what
you did best man do what all got us here
like you honestly don't get to the
marvel universe without Warner Brothers
success with the DC movies across three
[ __ ] decades you know it's like they
they built the [ __ ] trench one could
argue they built the track Kevin Feige
built a way better [ __ ] train and
opened up new routes and made the train
comfortable and like gave you food on
the train and I then turned the train
into a plane so you weren't even [ __ ]
on the ground anymore and then took you
to space like you know he just improved
upon something that was there yeah but I
think that Marvel Marvel to DC is
handcrafted versus automation in that in
that marvelous figured out like DC
you're right
they were first to the door Superman
Superman to and then the other Superman
which one talked about and in the the
Burton movies and the Nolan movies they
would work of singular filmmakers yes
doing a thing that took time and also by
the way filmmakers weren't even
necessarily like fans like you know Tim
Burton and historically Tim Burton was
like I didn't [ __ ] read Batman comics
and Chris Nolan historically was like
Batman I didn't grow up on Batman comics
but something about like the idea of the
character who was like blah you know
appealed to them and she yeah and it's
it's it's hand-tooled it's like a
[ __ ] Ferrari yeah they're only making
a hundred of those a year Marvin [ __ ]
your pun I saw the infinite
and it was beautiful laughs at me now
from beyond the grave
Marvel is making Hyundai's and people
love Hyundai's and they can make a
thousand ten thousand a hundred thousand
Hyundai's yes each one of same quality
each one here Marvel makes iPhones let's
be honest okay and everybody loves a
[ __ ] iPhone and stuff and other
people make other phones droids or
though they're not allowed here and scum
and villainy is really a C which is JC's
own [ __ ] joke sometimes you gotta give
props for props or do give it up for
JC's scum ability joke about Detroit's
pretty amazing but yeah let's say
they're they make iPhones what is Warner
Brothers / DC [ __ ] Android no they're
galaxy 7 clearly because that [ __ ] blows
up in your [ __ ] hand left and right I
mean but it should be like the [ __ ]
red phone on Commissioner Gordon's desk
yeah it should be this like artisanal
old-school beautiful piece of design and
engineering that you can't mass-produce
that you can't do any faster than you
can do it right and that's the problem
they're in a world where everybody's
getting what they want immediately and
they want to keep [ __ ] making the
perfect phone and you don't have time
for that it's time is their enemy at
this point true but yeah I mean I'm not
defending or anything but yet it seems
like maybe Marvel's not making the
perfect film but like as close as
possible to that type of film like in
terms of you know they maybe they don't
do like what Chris Nolan did so much so
that like I remember the summer that
Ironman came out like it came out in May
and then like Dark Knight came out in
July or something like that so for the
first few months it was a holy [ __ ] man
like [ __ ] Iron Man could be really
cool and that oh god the Joker you know
and suddenly he owned the rest of the
[ __ ] summer it just feels like they
they know how to make something they
moved the playing field rather than
compete in that world and say we're
gonna try to out Chris Nolan Chris Nolan
they're like we'll just redefine what a
comic-book movie is and hence what
excellence in a comic book movie could
be like suddenly for somebody like me
the bar goes to a place of now you just
got to show me
[ __ ] twenty people in costume in one
place and I'll [ __ ] sign away my
child's life to you
that's how devoted I could be yeah I
mean Marvel what they did was they
decided to stop making movies and they
made giant TV shows and each one of
these movies is an episode of the
massive Marvel Cinematic Universe and
the sweeps week episodes are Avengers
movies where we got to get all the
[ __ ] money we got all the [ __ ]
ratings that's when we're gonna put all
the money on the table
but then you know Thor - you know it's a
midseason episode of alias you know
really like whatever I guess it was okay
it's fine what an odd pull you got a
Garber on the brain on the brain but
like those movies and I love them to
death
they don't do for me what real movies do
for me which is have actual emotional
stakes at the end of each movie right
it's the ongoing story they're telling
it's the developing drama of these
characters but half the term like wheat
walked out of Thor and we're like you
know there's kind of nothing here it's a
ton of fun and I love being here and I
loved the movie it's gossamer-thin
he [ __ ] lost his eye spoilers yeah
you know he lost his eye and he lost his
dad yeah and then like two minutes later
it's joke time and I loved it it doesn't
land at all it doesn't live at all in in
Thor's heart in the way that you'd think
losing your [ __ ] dad would but those
movies aren't about that they weren't
close are you right though it's true
it's I I hold those movies to a
different standard it's television on
the grandest scale possible and Kevin
Feige used the showrunner and DC is
great at giving filmmakers movies to
make and so like the Dark Knight is a
perfect beginning to end and closed and
capsulated story that has emotional half
then it lands at the end and you feel
all the time but he's not about making
some 10 episode version of Batman he's
one of 93 good movies and maybe that's
just what DC's great and I would love
for them to do that because they're not
great at this so let's find the thing
that they are great at and do that fair
enough fair enough where do we start
what was the origin point for uh
Christopher Nolan knowing what is wrong
with DC movies right then we're like you
don't know but me and Mark sure do
the story of this podcast what do we got
next hey Margot Robbie speaking of a non
connected universe yes is developing her
own Harlequin moving really yeah by her
lonesome separate from Gotham City
sirens separate from whatever Gotham I
mean whatever Joker Harley movie that
they're talking about making right she
just wants to make us straight up Harley
Quinn movie I mean that's and look she's
the key to making it right now
she is Harley Quinn so whine if I'm her
yeah why not develop it why not why
you're not you're the star they kind of
have to do whatever you want so but why
not be like I want to develop one well
you guys are doing it I'm gonna do it
over here and whichever one works best
er hey man you go first I'll go second
whatever the [ __ ] but I want to if I'm
happy to play this character but now
it'll also like to take a bit more
agency with the character come up with
the story I think that's smart and like
you said it's about they're disconnected
universe where there's now three or four
different Harley Quinn movies and
development well they make all of them I
don't know will they make two of them
probably you know like that character is
so [ __ ] popular that I absolutely see
there being a Gotham City sirens movie
and then a Harley Quinn movie or Harley
Quinn Batman movie why not [ __ ] do
that thing they just released one
animated right Harley Quinn Batman or
something like that
Batman Harley Quinn yeah I can totally
sustain I mean look I honestly you do
good enough Batman project movie you can
make a Batman a year and people will pay
for it over and over and over again and
he's got like such a massive rogues
gallery that just don't put nine of them
in a movie just give them one [ __ ]
villain per per Fleck you'd get to 25
movies before anyone got [ __ ] bored
but you know if they want to continue
like if I was running things that would
be my spine and then everything else
would be like I'm gonna do like three
others per year three other [ __ ] hero
movies because they've got all the
characters and that's what it is right
now in this in in town it's the IP game
it's whoever has the most IP is gonna
win which leads back to today if news
broke again again that foxy Disney
Disney and Fox are in serious
negotiations and we and have been all
through Thanksgiving and we may in final
negotiations and we made
hearing a story as soon as next week or
the end of this week that that they've
bought sixty billion dollars worth of IP
from Fox which yes of course everybody
in this room is interested in the that's
the x-men that's the Fantastic Four that
means you could slam them into the
Marvel Universe and have the Marvel
Universe be United finally but it
doesn't stop there that's Planet of the
Apes
that's the x-files that's everything on
FX The Simpsons it's the [ __ ]
Simpsons it's like Disney would own so
much of everything that you love the
only place to go for it is the mouse man
where you're just like I'm [ __ ] fiend
and for it he's like pay up [ __ ] it's I
do you think the government lets that
out is that a monopoly they're not
buying all of 20th Century Fox or 21st
Century Fox they call it now the they
just be buying a big chunk of it Fox of
course to keep the TV network and right
and Hannity and and and all the sports
that they have but they just be out of
creating content movies and TV yeah I
mean I think it's it's it's awesome for
us as consumers it's less awesome for us
as creators why because that's one less
buyer that's one less studio like if
20th Century Fox goes away as a movie
studio as a TV studio right then that is
only six more places six more giant
[ __ ] companies one of which just
became a thousand times bigger than
everybody else
or this Disney yeah like I think that's
that that creates a somewhat unhealthy
business environment when one person can
dictate the terms and act independent of
competition really because they own
everything yeah but at the same time
like it's not like you know there were
[ __ ] five families and now we're down
to four new networks and studios have
erupted over the last [ __ ] five to
ten years alone Netflix Amazon Hulu are
massive players in the space maybe you
know 20th Century Fox just like look
it's not for us anymore there are others
out there we don't want to compete we
don't want to create a new [ __ ] we're
making a lot of money over here
you know maybe it was just time for them
to fold it could be it could be it's
just it's it's it's a somewhat dangerous
precedent to set and yes Netflix has all
the money in the world until they don't
because who the [ __ ] knows how many
people watching Netflix Hulu has got
five or six years left of this amazing
spending they're doing and I say this is
a dude who collects Hulu checks this
level of spending for this few viewers
is unprecedented like they're talking
about spending twenty five million
dollars in Episode four this [ __ ]
Amazon gamer throne Lord of the Rings
show yeah that's ridiculous and they
spent two hundred fifty million dollars
just to get the rights to make that show
how long can you keep spending that kind
of money and have no idea who the [ __ ]
is watching it and not being able to
monetize it through advertising and not
really being able to charge people more
than ten bucks a month for Prime and
that somehow makes this a sound
investment somebody will run out of
money sooner rather than later and then
lots of people run out of money and then
people who create content will have
nobody to sell it to and then we'll have
to be like hey so the Avengers in the
x-men fought one time while we're
staring at a desert of entertainment
choices because everybody's broke and
that movie will be called when podcasts
ruled the world wow man that's I I
didn't see the slippery slope that this
puts us on I just I was like everyone
else
[ __ ] x-men Avengers x-men of edge
that Infinity Gauntlet resets the
[ __ ] Barbara universe and introduces
read [ __ ] you know but you're right
that's one less place to go to but Fox
was never interested in my [ __ ]
anyways Wow but I'm its I guess I guess
you're right that puts a lot of balls in
their court but they're praying for it's
not like they're I guess deal in it I
mean I've said I've read some reports
online where people like this is a
[ __ ] crazy deal like 60 billion for
this it's not worth it but for for
Marvel and for Disney like number one
they'll get back the theatrical rights
for the entire Star Wars universe like
the first three movies the ones
everybody [ __ ] loves from back in the
day they'll get that back into the
Disney fold that's over at Fox right now
plus bringing those care
home that re-energizes marvel universe
which we know is coming to its close the
phase whatever phase were in the first
era ten years of marvel movies and it's
not like you know we're gonna check out
when they go but looks like we're gonna
lose some major heroes along the way why
not have back pocket not just like you
know ladies and gentlemen man thing but
instead like if I can ladies and
gentlemen for the first time ever
[ __ ] doing it right the fat since The
Incredibles the fantastic [ __ ] for
you know the first family of comics and
so they could re-energize make new loot
off of that you know turning into more
toys and stuff I could like this is a
company though you got to remember when
they bought Marvel they bought it for
what four six six billion six billion
when they bought Star Wars it was for
four billion and Pixar was four billion
okay so Wow yeah that sixty billion is a
[ __ ] lot but Fox is just like take it
or leave it will sell to Comcast if you
guys don't want it and they say in all
the reports the Fox would much rather
deal with Disney they'd rather see all
the [ __ ] go to Disney would they still
keep the name like would Fox the network
still be called Fox or what they called
is what happens at that point do they
keep the branding or they slowly phased
that out I don't know man I think
there's there's a world in which you
don't want the marketplace confusion so
they rebrand and rename themselves
something else but
the combination of Disney and Fox watch
these dicks
ladies and gentlemen some dick pics
alright so we're one step closer to one
army company we are speaking what is it
in wall-e by and large by and large
sooner or later we'll be under will all
be in flying chairs drinking cupcakes
out of straws fingers crossed the world
I've been praying for is that what the
great beyond looked like please tell me
yes a sailing on deck chairs like in
wall-e very large nobody judging anybody
else and [ __ ] drinking cupcakes out of
cups with straws
like any don't want it
utter saddened ition 'l love something
that you feel for one second but it just
goes on forever it seems and you don't
ever have to question it or where it's
coming from or who's around you you're
just like yay you can't wait to die
based on that description can't you
there I need they say you need to finish
some things down my time whatever the
hell it is wherever you are stand up let
me tell you so I can go I'm done yeah I
want the you can eat everything and not
get fat not you're not hungry that's
true no need for food yeah I like it
alright where we going next oh speaking
of worlds colliding Quentin Tarantino
wants to make a Star Trek movie yes and
I imagined when I heard that that I
would go to the Internet and the whole
internet would be like of course this is
what we want but there was a degree of
people going like I don't want him
anywhere near Star Trek and I'm like why
he was he watched it growing up like
he's a fan [ __ ] Kill Bill has like
you know revenge is a dish best served
cold cold Klingon proverb at the
beginning of the movie like he may not
be it dyed-in-the-wool Trekkie but like
this is a guy who's a natural
storyteller one of the greatest American
filmmakers ever lived and he's showing a
remote interest in Star Trek like I'm
glad that JJ was like get this man a
writers that's so smart like it's not
even like he's going I want to write the
script so you know be like it's a triple
again [ __ ] I dare you like
you're not it's not gonna be like put
through his filter like he's got a bunch
of ideas sat down with JJ and JJ was
like I'm gonna pull together a writers
room and we're gonna try to turn this
into the script and hopefully then he
goes forward and directs and why not man
like Quentin years ago wanted to direct
Casino Royale he wanted to make a James
Bond movie I think he even got so far as
to met with the broccoli family or
whatever but at the end of the day they
said no and you're like why like that
brand with his brand give it a shot
what's the worst that could happen they
wound up doing well with their real
the bond and stuff but it seemed like
there was a missed opportunity there
JJ smart enough to not let this be a
missed opportunity he's like Quentin
Tarantino remotely interested in a Star
Trek anything oh my god I'm gonna
[ __ ] follow this through and hope it
turns into something and I hope it turns
into something man feels like feels like
the right like he's directed things that
he hasn't written before yeah episodes
of ER and CSI of all [ __ ] things so
he can you know if you watch his own
films clearly he's a born a filmmaker he
knows what the [ __ ] he's doing but he
has proven that he can work with a
script that's not his grip just Quentin
Tarantino and I think on some level he
might welcome the idea of like let me
just see if I could do a Star Trek movie
I know he's all about experience like
you know I had phone call with him once
this is a sound name-dropping but I was
in Vancouver and I was shooting catch
and release and I had like a day where
they're like come on in at 6:00 in the
morning you're being the first seen up
and then she had got moved and so I
didn't like work until 5:00 at night so
you're just kind of sitting around and I
was in the trailer and I just watched
both kill bills back-to-back and so I
was in rarefied breathing space where I
was like I could literally call this
dude up and [ __ ] tell him how much I
enjoyed the movie again and I was in
such a fan space the headspace that I
did and I called left a message I was it
came in like I just finished watching
Kill Bill wanted to like is beautiful
but Kill Bill Vol to to me is fantastic
like I've seen you do things like Kill
Bill the volume one but volume two is
like you telling a family story it's
about a broken [ __ ] family it's
really kind of beautiful and and like
the Superman monologue is the the [ __ ]
so like thanks man that was cool and he
called me back like an hour later and we
just sat there chitchat and on the phone
and I said to him I was like we were
talking about the movies I think you're
gonna make another one ever and he goes
that's the thing I wasn't going to but
now I know how to make that movie like I
know how to make a karate movie I know
how to make a movie with martial arts
and it would feel weird not to put that
to the test or use those skills just
when I acquired them to suddenly put
them aside and never make another one so
I hope he does Star Trek because it
allowed it would allow him to put his
skills to work on something else that
isn't his a mainstream let him play with
somebody else's toys and that might wet
his app
site to do it further because he always
tells this [ __ ] story about I've only
making so many movies and then I'm
stopping and maybe this is a way for him
to be like look I am writing that many
but I'll [ __ ] jump in and direct a
Star Trek because I loved Star Trek when
I was a kid you know he's in his mind
he's he's kind of built his own mythos
and legend like even isn't as much as
whenever you see the trailers it's like
the tenth film by Quentin Tarantino
he's definitely keeping track and he's
got some sort of model in his head but
maybe this allows him to still keep to
that model he's kept to his entire
career but also go like oh I can play
outside of it
with things that I care about characters
and an IP that I give a [ __ ] about that
I was raised on yeah I mean I I longed
to see him do something in the
science-fiction world because I think
that he could do something amazing
science fiction and ironically Star Trek
is the most Western science fiction
thing ever and loves [ __ ] westerns
more than I love [ __ ] westerns but
good for you Quentin need three hours in
it [ __ ] Western go for it
but yeah it makes all the [ __ ] sense
in the world like it and I love the idea
of a filmmaker a lot like Steven
Soderbergh who decided I want to make
every kind of movie there is why not I
want to make a Western so I find one of
my god World War two romance I want to
make a spy thing I wanna make a heist
movie I want to make a tiny [ __ ]
disease movie like whatever it is I want
to try it if Quentin has that itch and
wants to get out of the Old West and I
want to make some wood spaceships all
for it mmm
big news great news across the board at
first when I saw is like this [ __ ]
fake news but it was real news like I
was like this is [ __ ] enjoyable man
it sounds like something that was made
up but [ __ ] it's it's the real deal I
hope it continues I think JJ deserves
like you know all the [ __ ] credit for
like immediately like how we all know
about that somebody [ __ ] talked and
I'm sure it might have been JJ going
[ __ ] spread the word man oh my god a
Quentin Tarantino Star Trek movie be
amazing talk about a way to reinvigorate
a franchise and and if it works with him
like give it to others and believe me I
in Lobby I'm not like give it to Silent
Bob I'd ruin it but I mean like if you
give it to Quentin not maybe other
filmmakers like you know it's not
without precedent Sam Mandy's did you
know American Beauty
and then he wind up doing [ __ ] James
Bond which is about as mainstream as it
gets and stuff so I I think I think this
could be the beginning of some man
that's kind of cool I like it
let me awesome we got two things out in
Netflix world okay the most obvious
thing in the world is that there will be
a third season of stranger things right
on what a shock yeah I'm sure they were
all sitting there sweating it
the duffer brothers who said that the
sect the third season will involve a
time jump because it takes them X amount
of years to write and direct and produce
a season of the show and this kids
getting older and I can't stop them from
aging so I think it's going to it's not
going to be a year in the life of these
kids anymore we might have to skip a
couple of years just because and they're
all signed for six years I think with
renegotiations happening after the next
season but we are absolutely getting
stranger things vol 3 [ __ ] yeah you'll
be getting stranger things until like
you're like I [ __ ] hate this show and
then you'll get three more seasons
I don't know watch them get jobs this is
[ __ ] they can go for a long [ __ ]
time I mean that's obviously it's
something that's crafted with love and
affection and they're not making them
crank it out hardware the like hey man
we need another one [ __ ] stat if
they're letting them time jump and stuff
like that like you know they're giving
them space to create so good for those
kids yeah and remember we talked a
couple of weeks ago about the chilling
Adventures of Sabrina yeah Netflix gave
it a two season order
oh [ __ ] so it's not even a CW CW show
because riverdale on the CW yeah
performed incredibly well on Netflix
over the summer to the point where more
people watch on Netflix than watched it
on the CW and so oh my god you should me
yeah CW is like how do we do' and tell
us netflix the the second season
premiere of Riverdale Riverdale was 60%
higher ratings than the first season
predominate on the Netflix bug got the
next clips Netflix bumps and Netflix
like [ __ ] it let's if we're gonna create
an Archie universe let's let's do it
let's own it and that's what they're
doing so 20 episodes out of the gate Wow
and that was actually a really good
concept for a show it sounds [ __ ]
dope like doing Sabri
by way of Rosemary's Baby yeah so it's
not like I've got a talking cat or maybe
it'll maybe she will if it's I'll get
the cattle be like [ __ ] Satan [ __ ] I
I like the idea I mean I guess they do
it in the comics there is a comic book
version of this yeah I mean they're
excited because there's 5000 some odd
characters in the archie universe and if
they're just gonna start plucking them
and creating their own interconnected
interweave ii [ __ ] thing why not then
you get an Avengers kind of movie going
I know Josie and the Pussycats and they
all got out of space that's [ __ ]
bad-ass good for them man that means
they'll probably be able to curse a
little bit too there'll be a bit more
liberal there than they can be on CW I
think so
I think so although they will have to
sell it internationally but who gives a
[ __ ]
right I think it'll sell foreigners what
else we got they seem to still want to
make a he-man movie for reasons that
boggle the mind but cuz there's a whole
generation it's not us it came right
after us of kids who like that's their
[ __ ] Star Wars they love though they
had all the toys and [ __ ] like that
bought man-at-arms a couple times I mean
I would like to direct them to Star Wars
instead of the [ __ ] Masters of the
Universe like hey you love that here's
the way [ __ ] better version of that
dude I know but III was never a man
cartoon guy but I did like that Canon
movie they made the Masters of the
Universe I think it's [ __ ] dope it's
a Ross Lundgren it's all about the
[ __ ] doll for the time it was made
like there's actual attention to detail
and like they made Courtney Cox's in it
and stuff it [ __ ] works and at the
fight at the end like you got Frank
Langella hamming it up his Skeletor and
he's like look that's be off I don't
battle and he [ __ ] it's I'm not even a
he-man fan I was like going he bad
gallop pretty good flick man but I who's
who's doing it David Goyer oh yeah he
did the did he worked with the Chris no
he worked with no one on it on those
those Batman movies and he directed
blade Trinity yeah which he did the
movie where the dudes a ghost and [ __ ]
like that's to solve his own death I
forget what that was called he's
directed before so he would do it
because as well he would direct it he's
sign on to direct and rewrite the script
the most recent draft is by McGee
Oh McGee does the draft of he-man uh-huh
yeah so that's a movie that at some
point will probably never happen but hey
Hollywood you guys you want to talk
about a [ __ ] thick universe of
characters they had a bunch of character
they do theirs and then you tiger in it
off to shira as well yes you could you
absolutely could it's gonna happen man
and arms coming at you like it or not
stink or the movie I mean I want
Thundercats before I want masses the
universe but that's just me really yeah
I think you'll probably get this before
you get Thundercats this is a more
mainstream I bet you if you just looked
at toy sales alone eman sold more than
Thundercats
I think we will get cyborg three before
we get either is there any more news
that is all the news that's fit to print
my friends that's the news you got yeah
yeah ladies and gentlemen we got a guest
tonight that we didn't tell you all
about I was went out to eat my lady the
other day went to one of my favorite
restaurants in town Merricks which is
they serve like tex-mex food behind
basics it's right over on Santa Monica
Boulevard I fell in love with the place
I like the dining there music is always
[ __ ] pop and eighties hard and [ __ ]
like that and my wife is like I think
you like it best because it's
predominantly gay but it's a fantastic
[ __ ] place I come in
maybe it's because I'm a bear in that
world and like they treat me real sweet
and whatnot I get all the chips I want
so it's uh it's one of my favorite
places so I went out there I want to eat
the other night and while we were there
I walked in I don't look around I
generally just kind of you know go to
the table and sit down try to look at my
wife so I didn't look around when I
walked in and then a dude comes over the
table and says hi and it was like one of
my favorite [ __ ] creators on the
planet and I was like holy [ __ ]
what are you
doing here he's like we like eating here
me and my lady come here all the time I
was like oh my god so I think him and I
are both total closet cases because we
both love eating at this boys eatery and
stuff like that it's pretty tremendous
man but he I said he's in town promoting
a show he's got a new TV show that's
about to start airing on sci-fi so I
said oh my god dude are you gonna be in
town this week come be on phat man I'm
Batman he's been on phat man I'm Batman
before at home and did one of the
greatest episodes of the show that
people still talk about to me to death
today both online and in person and [ __ ]
like that
so without further ado here to talk
about his show that's debuting on Sci Fi
called happy based on his comic book
give it up for the one the only the
living icon of [ __ ] comics and
thought Grant Morrison ladies gentleman
this is some slide for you I get this
yeah you guys can fight over this you
know what that seen in women in love yes
allenbys and all of the reason they have
to wrestle in front of the fire that's
what we want to see next week step in
between us right in the middle since
we're talking about Martok's jump in
jump in there all right
here in the space otherwise nobody could
see it Cameron got a face he's a hard
man not to see but that that he-man
movie was new guns new gods was new gods
it was think about it was like the old
one the one from Canada yeah the boom
tube and Skeletor was dark saying it's
right they call that the cosmic evil
again Kimmy was there
they stopped there as usual as usual you
have a huge long storied career and
we've talked about the character of
Batman deep cuts yeah on fat man Batman
last time you were on the show I think
you were headed toward the Wonder Woman
project that happened yeah yeah at the
first boot we've almost finished the
second one Yannick Beaucaire is kind of
on the last 40 pages and it's the Empire
Strikes Back of the charges there's the
[ __ ] top everything goes to hell was and
after posters you saw the Wonder Woman
movie yeah yeah what do you think I
liked I thought she was that the artists
gal gadot was really likable like she
will totally rootin for the girl Chris
Payne was great two of them together
with grape I'm looking at the Amazons
and I'm thinking what so you've had a
3,000 years and these women haven't
developed a washing machine yet and it's
kind of my take on the Amazons because
bited William Moulton Marston is
original which was in 3,000 years they
develop philosophy they develop flying
machines they got purple rays that can
heal the dad you know they can do all
this stuff so I can like the idea that
the Amazons pose a threat
what pose at least an alternative and I
failed it in the movie when when Diana
and and this I mean this isn't even my
take on it's my
she went to see this and she said Diana
goes in there and she takes on the
generals and it's like you shouldn't be
doing this since she stomps in but it's
from a place of naivety she doesn't get
the culture it's official wash it's not
like she has a credible alternative can
I think in there was early Mastan
stories the Amazons were declared at the
credible feminist alternative to
masculine culture and that's what's kind
of missing from the movie they haven't
developed in 3,000 years they're still
raiding horses and why can each other
with leather swords no Cana that
wouldn't have happened you know it seems
it's not enough you know what did you
see women would have stopped there
developed a culture so that's why I
can't miss from it but I thought as a as
a movie it was greed that the leads
would create I mean what do you think
I've dug it I bought it but I did like I
was talking to my friend about it just
recently who hadn't he I hadn't spoken
to him since it came out and he hadn't
seen it and he goes did they do the
invisible jet and I was like bro they
didn't even call her Wonder Woman like
not once in the movie they always call
her Diana Diana and stuff so in their
version like we call the Paradise Island
where kids Thomas Kiera they don't have
the tech at least as presented in the
movie whereas in the comics she left the
island with the invisible jet like it
was from there yeah I mean these these
these women had like I see it had the
medical technology they had invisible
jets they had you know what planes that
would be one supersonic speed and I
can't awake that you know Hippolyta had
a magic mirror and she could see
anything happen in anywhere any time and
that kind of that I wish there been a
bit more of that so that they were an
actual credible alternative to the
patriarchy no let's talk about Batman
real quick so you got a lot of history
Batman
you had this historic run on Batman
where he was gone Darkseid got rid of
them at one point so then dick became
Batman and Damian the character you
created became Robin and then Batman
franchised and did Batman Inc and stuff
like that so at any given point like
working with DC with
wherever like you can't do that don't do
that please don't do that because it
seems like they let you do whatever just
kind of Levi I consider please you know
just just do your thing because it
worked you know as long as the things
work and always baffles me satsang yeah
hey that tail did that work at all but
when it works it that's that's it so one
reward and undie see what happy just
seal kid what keep doing this keep doing
it keep doing it keep doing it and I
still look back and I hope that folks
that I get away with it we had a debate
last year about casting of Batman
because Ben Affleck wants to leave and
he's I'm interested it's too hard being
Batman the cows too heavy whatever and
and so else to Evie Evie I said that
where's the cow and and so we got into a
little bit of a debate about whether or
not a black actor could play Bruce Wayne
I
oddly enough felt that and it needed to
be a white actor because of who Batman
is because of the legacy vote money
because of the responsibility that the
way I built in four generations that the
wings and Gotham are intertwined and so
with and so on he was elbow where do you
come down on that particular everybody's
gonna see if it's Doctor Who it's
address if it's like Han Solo in said
dresses so yeah I mean yeah it should be
a clip I guess I'm with you I think
Batman's representative of a whole class
of sorry a whole class of people who you
know that East Coast wealthy quite
retching it I kind of love the tension
that he does he fights crime he beats up
junkies and he's a billionaire and it's
nice not only does obviously it's a
reductive reading to see you know it's a
Marxist kind of reading about man to say
that's all he does but it's still in
there and the odds are taint you know I
don't think you'd get that if it was
there to say oh by don't you get the
same there's something unhealthy and
unholy
all right let's talk happy
last time you brought the first issue of
the comic and you were like hey this is
something I'm working on check it out
and it's now a [ __ ] TV show yeah it's
not as that well just hummed over a long
period turn you know how these things
work it was harmed over years and it
seems like instances now those
billboards at last but it happened over
a long time you know with a bunch of
people who run to brian clover UCP and
the guys original film and then they
brought and brian taylor and i was
totally into the crank movies you know
especially that kind to you which I
really love
so Brian and I worked on the pilot and
it took the usual years of development
and then thing catches fire you know
last year were in New York and it was
minus 10 degrees in the middle of the
night doing these overnight sequences
and I just thought how the hell do I get
myself into this I usually sit in a
little Tower and Scotland overlooking
the water
with cats playing a boo and everything's
cool I know I'm swaddled up in this tent
in Manhattan minus 10 degrees well it's
freezing well so the we did the show
there and and the funny thing was that
once it was packed up they had to shoot
this Christmas show and in August in New
York so it's the most amazing there's uh
Turley convincing you believe it was
went er they managed to cheer all the
trees and people walking by in the
shorts the Gowanus is utterly convincing
but it was it was a weird one once it
happened it happened like a train
explain the concept of the show for
those at home completely unfamiliar the
concept bit story I'm sorry I when it's
in sci-fi tomorrow night so the story is
a simple that's the it's about an ex-cop
who's I was once a great cop and he's
fallen from grace he's now ended up
walking doing hits for the mob to
finance his love of drugs and it and
eczema cream and all kinds of things
that are completely unsavory so he's
doing a hit one night and everything
goes wrong he shoots the wrong guy and
he has a heart attack and when he wakes
up in the ambulance there's a little
blue unicorn
hovering above him unicorn with wings
like the kind of unicorns you usually
see when you've got the DTS and the
unicorn tells them it's a local girls
imaginary friend and no one else in the
world can see this unicorn except hero
next sacs that's this fallen cop and
suddenly he has to ask himself am i
hallucinating is this for real and the
unicorn says we have to save this kid
something really bad is going to happen
to this kid before Christmas and we have
to savor and that's kind of the the
basic law of this thing and then it
spirals off it goes off in directions
quite different from the original
graphic novel it gets quite cosmic and
wheels so we'll excited how were the
conversations with sci-fi like given the
intensity of the material like I saw the
pilot earlier today yeah yeah and it's
[ __ ] bonkers and it's way extreme for
even like basic cable what were those
conversations like like how much delay
it was amazing it actually really just
said we want to we want to we want to
take this as far as you guys can take it
and they didn't pull much back I mean
there are scenes in there that are
coming up which is ludicrous there's
been nothing like I'm on television and
possibly shouldn't ever have been
anything like until vision but it's too
late so another did they were super
supportive and I think what Kaena sold
is because I mean you've seen it so that
the violence is quite extreme but the
same time it has a cartoon quality and
Chris Meloni just brings this he's so
likable that it could be mashing a man's
head in with a fire extinguisher and you
still think he's a really nice guy and
you want to be his friend so I think he
brought something really special to the
rule and that absorbed those of a lot of
craziness you know things that in
another show could have been really
bleak and violent and this sure kind of
Tom and Jerry what was your process in I
guess the collaboration of it all given
that comics is very much from your pen
to the page to the artist to the reader
there's not a lot of layers between your
intent and the fun but television is
there's 87 different layers like how did
you find that process not die enjoy
don't wanna sleep is just like
translation you know I like the idea
taking us
Orion doing a version of it because I
think stories are always malleable they
can always change that never say in
stone so I cannot just go into the idea
of working with people and initially it
was just me and Brian doing the pilot so
I cannot land the television and then we
were in the writers room and a whole
bunch of other writers were throwing
ideas in the pole and that was great
because you can just sit back for the
entire day and they do all the work it's
not like comics well the deadlines on
and you have to have this thing finished
any of us you know there's eight other
people have thrown ideas and so I
actually have really enjoyed the process
and I love being able to translate the
story in a completely different medium
and play up to the strengths of
television rather than comics and kind
of expand the mythology and then though
that does it does it sort of excite you
about maybe taking some of your other
work and trying to translate it to TV
like I think there's a fantastic we
three TV show to be made yeah yeah I
mean I thought I think that would be
cream it's a whole bunch of them us
always always the ones that people say
it's completely unfilmable those are the
ones I want to do you know like the
Invisibles and the filth and CGI and I
have take so in them but you know we'll
see what happens once this hopefully
opens the doors if it does you know
people are into and I hope they are then
yeah I mean I'm sure other things may
happen but but yeah that is that
unfilmable ones I really wanted to what
I what up your stuff in the past have
you seen translated to another medium
nothing no thing in the first yeah the
first one is the Missoula Superman they
did the the animated yeah yeah Dwayne
McDuffie did a really great you open up
maybe that was the first thing at scene
that had any of my kenneth dialogue
brought to life by actors so this was
the first time and I was you know
hanging a bit with actors and I really
enjoyed that whole thing talking to them
and getting a take on things in the way
they would improve and create characters
Chris Meloni
is that cop yeah he's the lead on that
and who's doing the voice of the
important part
not on the boys oh my god that's awesome
that's kind of perfect no he is a day
just Niels is good it just boggles the
mind that there is such a deep catalogue
of your work create around and even in
DC that this is the first thing yeah DC
is not just like [ __ ] it let's get this
to 2-channel like we could do Grant
Morrison all day every day
yes I'm tell me about it but no
seriously I mean and and this is the one
that most people would think is kind of
least definitive of my work and the
weird thing with the TV issue is once we
expanded it it's become way more like my
kind of stuff you know so it's a lot
more bigger mythology there's bigger
stuff going on but it's weird that this
was the one that there is so probably no
one representative of what I do is the
one that can I opened the door grant
wrote one of my all-time favorite
stories not even just comp oh yeah yeah
just stories in the world with Rock of
Ages on that Jael everyone oh my god to
this day like can make me well up by the
time you get to the black racer issue
just such a weird old [ __ ] story and
that version of Batman had been broken
utility buddy did I decide and then
finally and then went through like
decade or more
yeah inhalation just to outlive them and
just to eventually break him yeah and
then he punches it on as well yes and
you go with the logic he was just like
you don't know what it's like to be real
you've never made you know make yourself
so he needs the knowledge what does it
feel like to be human well become human
and you Lana
the minute Metron becomes human
consciousness like remember when they
were with the in the beginning of the
story of the whirligig or were like oh
yeah they were trapped inside the
Joker's brain and or or know their place
where he was like with John Jones that
Martian Manhunter was like I can create
a frontal lobe that's like mimic the
Joker mix the Joker so I could think
like a psychopath
and find our way out of here give me a
moment and there's just a shot of him
like him it's not like I said changes
but then he just goes her this way and
starts leading him and he said like at
one point he's like his his thinking is
terrifying was such a [ __ ] cool
concept the the there's that story which
I feel like would be an amazing [ __ ]
movie hmm
but honestly probably like your most
famous work that screams to be adapted
as a movie and in a world where you know
we were talking about which direction
take the Warner Brothers movies yeah
Batman Arkham Asylum would be [ __ ]
fantastic you get to showcase yeah yeah
the entire rogues gallery it's a great
simple content man you want to talk
about like cheap like it's one you're
basically you're an Arkham it's no
different warehouse so this is it could
be like a totally Logan stripped down
[ __ ] version of one man in a weird
suit and a bunch of weird people in a
[ __ ] scary place and like in a world
where you see that trailer for that New
Mutants movie were they taking a horror
movie approach yeah yeah that's what you
would take like that man is a harmless
to see that it was like and I think it
would work you know but who would do you
think but its cheapest [ __ ] that movie
cost 15 million dollars I mean honestly
it's Warner Bros let's be honest 50 but
that's cheap for them we don't know how
to spend 15 min and he say Blanc could
make that big the game with the games
the game was great you know so they
proved that they could do something with
it which is a little more populist and
easier but yeah if they took that basic
substance but you'd want some I don't
know you'd want some weird 1930s
surrealist director yes you want
somebody [ __ ] up and on drugs
I'm not a saying give me the job darn
you hit one yes Fincher doing [ __ ]
absolutely Arkham Asylum what do you
think it's hard to beat Fincher David
Lynch David Lynch that all Twin Peaks
baby so well hold on maybe not
oh come on I'd to see I'd see a version
from last but I don't know we want to
give a Markham Asylum first three
episodes will be who he wanted to do
you're one in a big bad way and but then
didn't wind up doing it yeah I'd watch
it mother was I thought mother was
interesting as [ __ ] and also bold the
[ __ ] so yeah why not him
alright man that's so when can they
watch and is it all done is it one of
these shows that's like we did ten
episodes and we're finished well we did
they and it's that's the first season
it's also around Christmas it was kind
of it's a wonderful life for this new
generation of us and it's yes that's
tomorrow night and hope people take it
and it goes from this like I say a hyper
violence to absolutely et stale
sentimentality but the tears will be
running in your face because Tinker
Bell's dying and it's like so we kind of
covered everything and I'm kind of
interested to see what people think I
know I remember when I was in San Diego
this summer for IMDb friend of Maya saw
me it was like I just got cast unhappy
and I was like get the [ __ ] out of here
they're making happy and it's Jo Reitman
who know Jules could be you know he's
the dude from if you saw Jay and Silent
Bob strike back
he was the first date D when Chris rocks
like this movie's gonna make house party
look like house party to anyone house
party three shut the [ __ ] up so who's he
playing in this he's the Santa guy yeah
he's playing the just the most corrupt
Santa you've ever seen and the costume
design is great the the designs are like
Batman villains you know that the
Santa's amazing he's just covered and
all this Christmas [ __ ] that he's been
accumulating for years so it's like a
crab and he's built this shower in
demand and pure joy that the court
weighed about three times to his weight
and he was dragging her in the place the
costume itself this costume was insane
it's like solid you know you could live
in it it's like an igloo it's amazing
but it's covered in stuffs covered in
dolls and bundled faces and Christmas
things so it's amazing cause was it like
to see like
and again like this is not the most
obvious choice in the world and I'm
sorry to go first what is it like to see
something that you've probably never
thought would be [ __ ] turned into
something before some of the other
things you know what do you think um
it's ridiculous it's like what the [ __ ]
is a total what the [ __ ] yeah I've seen
those seen those posters on Sunset cuz
that words are everywhere without
without words like this thing but I'd
always imagined good dating that seating
there would be something is there
updated eventually you know and suddenly
to see it was like it was being pitched
into hallucination congratulations you
wants to grab for Q&A yeah sure so we
can open it up to it to you as well
all right folks we're now about to enter
the queue a portion of fat man on Batman
and I've brought some [ __ ] gifts not
from Whole Foods it's just a Whole Foods
back for the choosing when you ask the
question you get to pick from the spine
array of stuff we've got a pop we've got
some injustice figures we got a
Harlequin Hulu girl and we got Batman
socks so if your question is worthy
enough we don't have 40x tickets they
sound like Frankenstein Alaska which one
is that Frankenstein where oh my god
they're gonna take your DC card away
someone Gandhi never looked at I know as
somebody else's justice rendering of
Solomon Grundy
all right JC you got a mic yep mike is
live throw your hands in the air wave
like it just don't pick somebody ready
bang you got City we're starting off how
are you I'm good so good question for
mr. Morris and for all three you a
question spent with
it was infinity war being pretty much
the end all the be all especially for
this pain and everything studios Billy
and everything up you guys as writers
and creators and just overall awesome
people how do you feel now since
everybody's on like pretty much the same
page you know
amid knocking stuff out of the park with
the exception of certain movies which we
won't talk about but my question we you
guys do you think it was more that the
writers and producers on the shows like
American Gods Game of Thrones The CW
shows the guys that work for Feige and
all them is it just there you know
there's just that they get it and they
realize it or is it more of a right
place right time type of thing and do
you guys filled it where we will end up
in the future it's just gonna get better
or is it a person apart might get worse
I think for me in terms of like Marvel
is easy to point to it seems obvious
like they've got a showrunner like Mark
said like Kevin Feige is telling one
long story and everybody gets to make
their movies within that big story but
he's got a long con go and it's gonna
pan out for him and I think the other
thing they do that's interesting is
whenever I look at the credits I never
see a writers name where I'm like oh
it's that person like they're they're
willing to take take new talent on
because old talent I suspect this might
have something to do with it aside from
being expensive and [ __ ] but Oldtown
them and I'm not including myself in
that I'm just saying like it was a bunch
of names say 20 names like other the
highest-paid screenwriters they don't go
after those cats they kind of go after
people don't cost as much but more
importantly they go after cats where
they can be like this is what the story
is going to be worked within those
parameters and I think if you went to
people who are like I wrote this and I
wrote that they don't want to have terms
dictated to them but I think it works
better if you've got somebody in the god
seat going like these are all the beats
you got a hit within your story
everything else go crazy do that so I
think they're I think they're doing the
smart thing they're not you
the same [ __ ] writers that have been
used over and over again they're using
fresh names and and while they let them
do their movies clearly you know Thor 3
Thor Ragnarok marched to the beat of its
own drum but it still also had all the
beats needed to get us to Black Panther
and you know Avengers infinity war
there's still a story being told
underneath that story I think that's the
smart way to go for these movies
particularly I don't think you could do
that
or should do that with you know [ __ ]
other flicks but with comic book movies
that you want to connect a universe the
way they're doing that seems to work you
guys do you just think that the formula
gets better you know they figured out
who each new one they figured that make
those connections how to make them
better and clearer and it's like
algorithms you know sin machines will be
right in these movies know even better
they've already got programs that are
doing this stuff so that the pain of
each one of these movies it's like it's
more Rephaim that's more perfectly tuned
to what the audience are looking for and
they'll just keep doing that I mean who
knows what the pinnacle of that will be
our movie so beautiful it breaks our
hearts and kills us I think that at some
point every story has to end you know
like an every good story needs the the
final act right and I'm very curious
what Marvel's final act is gonna be and
when they're gonna start nudging us
towards that I mean there was the point
like we all love the first season of
Lost we all kind of endured the second
season of Lost but by the third season
lost you like you got to come up with
where the last season losses we can't be
here indefinitely and only when they
decided there is where we're going they
pointed to the [ __ ] bleachers and
said I'm gonna hit a shot there do you
start to get actual story residents do
you actually start to get it to mean
something by the end of it so I'm really
curious were Kevin Feige how much longer
this long con is gonna go on for and
these movies are good because they're
what they need to be you know like
they're not trying to I mean [ __ ]
it's why Thor Ragnarok was so good
because a fella gets what it demanded to
me it's why guardians were so good
it was this movie needs to be this thing
and we're gonna do that version of it to
the best we possibly can
it's what Deadpool worked so well and
why attempted mimicking Deadpool don't
work so well because they knew what that
pool was and made the best version of
that thing so yeah I'm just really
curious to know when and what the final
act looks like you went a prize give him
a round of applause take us someplace JC
how are you I'm doing great how are you
so [ __ ] good
my question is for mr. Morrison yeah
back at comic-con you talked about doing
an Arkham Asylum sequel yep
any indication as to when that might be
released wait what yeah what is it what
would it be
I mean don't give us the story but what
what no Isis peacefully I was talking to
Chris Paul nominee what you want to do
some Batman again I said look I've
always thought that when I was
completely jumping the shark in my
career was all but I would do how come I
said on - are we there so let's do it
and we come up with this idea and we
just really wanted to do and it's Kor
casis or father it's it's a kind of
Damian version about mine it's in the
future but we're not doing any of that
dystopian stuff I want it to be like a
fringe graphic novel like one of those
de you know Mobius things like I like
the Lydian I love boolean you know it
was like the worst but I really loved it
and we was [ __ ] beautiful it was the
most amazing looking thing and just
filled with all that detail so Chris and
I are going to do this thing but he's
he's just walking with Kirkman right now
he's about to finish the project and
we're starting next year but the the
ideas does get them a long lead in so
that we can release it for as a thousand
years after the first one came out
whatever it would be anniversary
yeah I did be at one shot yeah just went
2019 is the 30th anniversary so we're
going yeah but can you believe it
this sounds weird to say but like I
remember driving to three different
comic book stores to secure as many
[ __ ] copies as we could because the
place we went to we could only get one
copy each and we're like well I want one
to open one to [ __ ] put into my
collection on open and one to be able to
deal to a comic book store and it goes
up so but they were brilliant they fell
apart on contact lose those early
editions alchemist arm you will just
open them in all the pages fully pocket
taro cards you just have to put them in
in any order and it still make sense
looking classy like nobody would
remember it now because now it's the
standard everyone does hardcover books
and I make these beautiful coffee table
books but it was at an age where you
were like you were so proud to bring it
into your home well I can show your
parents like this is comic books man a
classy book that could go on a shelf
just because it was hardcover with his
lip you know is that dust jacket it just
felt more legit and then there was like
gorgeous [ __ ] art inside that was a
historic book 30 years ago yes so the
new ones going to commando be a complete
you'll deface the how are you sir oh
good thank you was that mark yeah react
wanted to thank you for clerks I wanted
to thank you for genius and I want to
thank Morrison you know for everything
but really my question is like for mr.
Morrison how do you go between writing
something like Multiversity and
something like all-star Superman like
how do you
I don't know fix your brain to write
something where it's easy for everyone
to get and then something like
Multiversity I just I follow what I
think that the story needs you know and
sometimes the story leads to in places
that I wish I hadn't taken me and and
it's gets weirder it gets kind of broken
up I just gotta follow and with Superman
we were trying to do something really
classical that would last for all time
most of the other stuff I do I just
wanted to be ready and I don't expect it
to be remembered and 5 10 years or
whatever I expect it to be obliterated
so it's kind of more like live
performance but Superman was seriously
done to try and kind of yeah so it was
designed to be timeless so the other
stuff is definite it's more like
experiment what can you do in a live
performance you know you've got an idea
for a superhero story how far can you
stretch the notes before it turns into
something else so far can you you know
bend it before it changes and most of
these things that I kind of do them as
experiments oh no you know obviously
sometimes the experiments might seem as
if they've gone too far of the field of
but I can I just got to follow you know
with Batman it was all about the entire
structure of that guy's career like the
entire history of Batman could we make
that one guy's life and all of them must
have seen the seven soldiers was the
idea could we do a super team well none
of them ever meet but the stories
crossover to this degree would actually
they managed to beat the villains
without ever crossing paths and all of a
majestic if I hoped I'd do this justice
leaves like myths you know I could going
on x-men was a soap opera and I was
really pushing myself to experience
these miserable emotions and all of them
you just fear for well okay what's the
four masses the soup up was really
different until in the methodological
tales of the Justice League and you know
what I've a comic like the Invisibles is
very different from doing you know are
we three which is okay it's an animal
stories with a bit this thing began
metal Anna and so honestly its form
dictates content I was at content
dictates form whatever is that so what
is the story need was that will doesn't
want to go was asking for and distorted
can the medium be to carry that story if
need be
hence things like Final Crisis
hey I got a question before we jump back
into the audience so you talked about it
on the podcast when you're on my show
once but since Krista over here has
merged with the infinitive oh yeah
didn't you have yeah mr. [ __ ] here the
infinite you told me about the story
where you guys made so much money from
Arkham Asylum we were like let's go -
lets go Jeff Scott man do and you know
I've been doing a lot of like occult
stuff and magic stuff before that and
again I'll try and condense this because
it tuns in it can I the greatest hair of
this [ __ ] story again but the idea
was we saw this this guy on a TV show
BBC TV show as art historian Dan
Cruikshank and he was talking about the
Buddha and walking in the footsteps of
the Buddha and there's this temple and
Nepal called chuan boudnath which
apparently you have if you can claim the
stairs there is eight billion times more
holy than anywhere else on earth and 365
steers if you can do on one long full of
the area of guaranteed enlightenment so
I mean a fan but I got guaranteed
enlightenment for who walk for a plane
ticket okay so we buy the ticket we got
to Katmandu we do the the stairs and it
was quite easy you take a big breath and
you go up the stairs and basically a few
days later I was on the roof garden and
this thing started to happen and yeah I
mean I like like what you were talking
about that been taken off this office of
the four dimensional universe had been
able to rotate around and look back at
it as a structure and see from a can of
five dimensional perspective for all
time and all space was contained in one
simultaneous object and everyone that I
knew was there but they were in the form
of what seemed to be silver
morphing blobs of mercury and when they
pass three you'd get entire emotional
symphonies of someone you'd know and
like your mother your father it was
heavy so it seemed like a place it
seemed that it's a time but what they
said to me which was incest and show me
the universe of time and I said what the
[ __ ] well why am I here they said we
asked for it
he ran up the stairs you know you were
you asked if your psychic asked and they
just basically said look we make in this
world we will have this five dimensional
source beyond space it's beyond time we
don't have time right you have time so
we can't grow things the only way to
grow something is to make time because
that's where things grow things grow and
tighten any time they grow so they
basically that we grow our children
we've select a planet in your universe
and we plug a kid into and it starts off
as a single cell and the ocean that
grows then it goes for billions of years
and it puts a all these fronds and fans
and it feels like distinct and
individual it's like all the fingers and
a hand think the safe yeah but they're
actually not they're all just part of
the same hand and they show me this
thing and they just said this huge
entity that's living on your planet and
has been surviving on your planet and
feeding off your planet for the last
three and a half billion years is about
to grow up and turn into one of us now
go back and tell everyone
no I wasn't it was actually no I found
it hard that the question was yes but
yeah but and I mean that that makes a nd
and tell him you know I tried everything
in the nineties after that experience I
do everything to get back to this place
because it was much more real than here
it was way more real than this that the
definition was way higher it was like a
thousand million bet you know computer
simulation the colors was so much pewter
and this seems like a kind of flickering
Charlie Chaplin film by comparison so
yeah I could never recreate the same
experience but it kind of fueled a lot
of the work that I did for four years
and the Invisibles and somehow stouts I
figured it was a view version with
attempt
loop's seizure is this what the
afterlife looks like is this what the
fifth-dimensional is no idea but I can
do this that's that's what happened I
just went to Hearst Castle good luck
following that question where we going
next JC yeah so we heard tonight in
honor of my husband's birthday so I want
to play his least favorite game remember
when you said so Kevin in so many
podcasts you talked about how much you
hate tusk and I love tusk I only joke
about hitting is my favorite thing I've
ever done well I wanted to explain that
process about how you talk about it in
all the podcast and and how how it
started because I am NOT artistic and
I've never created so I wanted to hear
your story about how it was it an
execution or what people said about it
because you often talk really negatively
about it mmm but I also often very talk
negatively about you guys don't hear it
as much anymore Mallrats for the first
ten years of Mallrats life it was the
redheaded stepchild and a punchline to
many jokes and then Jersey girl took its
place for a long time
that was my first horror movie I would
say before a red state or test and then
toss to Jersey girls place but only for
a little while because then yo Gosar's
beat them all
so suddenly there is an easier go to I
always find it best to make fun of my
[ __ ] before somebody else does I believe
in stealing the Thunder if you you know
I grew up fat so if you are in the
schoolyard and you're like I'm fat then
the bully doesn't call you facts like oh
he [ __ ] knows it and they move on and
[ __ ] so I've always been the person
that's the first to make fun of his
flicks but I love them regardless like
you know they exist because I love them
I I don't I get that people can find
flaws in them but you know I I love him
the debt they're exactly what I wanted
him to be or with based on the material
I had to work
to the budget or something like that
even cop-out was the movie that like
considering what a pain in the ass it
was to shoot and how we had to kind of
work through one of the leads like I'm
happy with the end result my old man
would have [ __ ] loved that movie like
it was his kind of flick he was dead
when we made it them never make a movie
for a ghost that's what I learned on
that [ __ ] so at the end of the day
I'm a kid them but I [ __ ] love the
movie I love tusks to death I think it's
it too is like mall rats where after
mall rats like the first two years like
people just [ __ ] on it and then slowly
the real audience kind of started
appearing first time I met the real
audience for tusk I was at where
Ringling College in down in Sarasota an
art college like film students and [ __ ]
like that
not for clowns not for clowns so they
that was where like I met a bunch of
people were like I [ __ ] love to us or
people who are like I always thought you
were [ __ ] until tough that blew my
mind I'm like wow no I got [ __ ] clerks
what a sellout I'm like that movie but I
guess like tusk is a completely
different bar so no I loved it to death
I make I get it but it's also coming
into its like its aging well as I said I
had a question from work too I think you
brought it up tonight about Batman
couldn't be black and ever since I heard
that in the podcast it's been kind of
like in the back of my mind so I feel
like the reason you said he couldn't be
black was because of centuries of
slavery and oppression and systemic
racism and in comics where we suspend so
much reality shouldn't that be where we
correct history and kind of create the
heroes that couldn't be because of the
mistakes that we made or do you stand by
that Batman just can't be black I I feel
like it's less the systemic racism and
ongoing sort of siege of bigotry and
more it's about it's about old money
it's about Batman about the Wayne family
landing in the new world in this 17th
century and they were they built Gotham
hand-in-hand with with the other robber
barons of their day
and the responsibilities that the Wayne
family over the course of that time
feels for Gotham City the the fact that
they preyed on it for centuries the fact
that they tried to help it for centuries
the fact that they they bled for it and
tried for it and stole from it for
centuries but the time Thomas Wayne
comes of age and decides to stop being
part of that legacy and becomes a
surgeon and decides to give back fully
knowing and being cognizant of the fact
that for centuries his family has done
great things and bad things for the city
when Thomas Wayne has a son he teaches
that son to carry that forward like for
those eleven years of Thomas Wayne is
still in Bruce Wayne's life it's you
have a responsibility to this city son
you can't just take from and you have to
give to it he saw the Wayne foundation
and the charities and all that stuff
and so when the Wayne's died that kid
broke him and crazy internalizes all of
that stuff to then become Batman and I
don't think you just get to be Batman
like Oprah's kid should she ever have
one she's a billionaire she's a black
billionaire there are no old black
billionaires there's Brandi new ones and
if Oprah's kid decides that oh [ __ ] my
parents got killed he's not putting on a
[ __ ] costume and fighting crime
that's not how that works because that's
not built into him that that level of
Barnacle over the ages is not part of
that story so I think Batman for that
reason needs to be that person who same
ways or Oh
needs to be a Spaniard like you can't
have an Indian Zorro and love to see an
Indian sorrow but you can't do that
because it's about old California it's
not landed gentry it's about aristocrats
is about all that [ __ ] and it's cultural
specificity and as long as you keep that
as long as you follow that thread then
that's all well and good
Zorro could be a lady absolutely she
could be done yet della Vega as much as
you'd be done to the Vega but it's it's
it's about what that character requires
to be that character otherwise it's
somebody new and maybe awesome new is
great make a new hero for each yourself
of the play and make him be the first
and only as opposed to the seventh and
best but still I think that there's that
reason for me he still holds water
let's [ __ ] solid give it up for mark
man
I'm smart shittin there all right where
we going next
now you win a prize by the way come up
there and get that prize happy birthday
kid give them up give it up for him he's
a perfect kid let your lady do all the
work you get the Breslin
nice we're all studying you now of
course you took the big one well done
well done
that are liquid now what about JC where
we're gone Kevin hey love the show thank
you you a great job great Jersey my
friend thank you my go Kings go how you
doing so good awesome [ __ ] metal
two-part question for you first part can
I get a picture with you after the show
absolutely second part if you were to
get a tattoo of your favorite comic-book
character what would it be and where
[ __ ] I guess I mean it sounds it's kind
of a standard answer but I'm a huge
Batman fan so I would definitely get
Batman where [ __ ] I got a lot of skin
you know I could probably put all the
rogues gallery on me as well but I think
like Jason the guy spent my life
standing next to in movies and in real
life he has put tattoos on his calves
that looked kind of badass he put like
the Justice League symbols on his calves
back in the day so uh you know I got a
fairly large calf I think that has to do
with the fact that the rest of me is big
and so when I walk I that's the only
part of my bias developed I walk the
dogs all the time my wife makes fun of
me she's like [ __ ] gun show because
my calves like she took a picture of him
once and I I look ripped like when I'm
walking up the hill and I was like
that's weird because the rest of me is
real flappy but I realized like I walk
on these [ __ ] all the time and these
[ __ ] got to hold up like a thousand
pounds so they've gotten real developed
so I imagine I could put Batman and a
muscular looking Batman on one of my
[ __ ] calves that'd be kind of cool
and plus they'd be exposed all the time
right because I'm always wearing shorts
so but at the same time then it would be
like well [ __ ] DC they don't need any
promotion with that character put your
[ __ ] self on your own cat
so I'd probably default to silent bob on
my calf instead but silent bob dressed
like Batman best of both wheels you get
pick a prize man well done all right
where we going next JC two prizes legs
well really one pair socks well it's
just one sock in a bag no I mean but you
know yeah I guess there's two but then
there's yeah we're down to the socks
Mandy I'm sorry for that question I
don't know my voice is terrible I'm so
sorry Jake from Chicago how's it going
so we're getting to that time at the end
of the year when people are putting out
their top-10 lists and critics groups
you're voting for best of the year and
we're sort of starting to hear it you
deserve better than socks I like where
this is going I'm just like what is the
movie that's not getting a lot of
attention from 2017 that you wish we're
getting maybe more accolades at this
time this year that's awesome I want
that really well I think is not getting
attention Briggs b-bear was my one of my
favorite [ __ ] movies of the year if
you love movies about creativity and
[ __ ] art if you like to laugh you
like to field movie at all the fields
I've watched it now three times at home
wonderful movie about the joy of
creation and the therapy of art and and
just you know it incredibly well acted I
was kind of like a little hard program
why like as if these institutions matter
but I was really bummed that the nd
Spirit Awards didn't [ __ ] recognize
that flick I was like Jesus Christ it's
a low-budget movie and it's about the
joy of [ __ ] making movies so I feel
like that was overlooked in a big bad
way you guys well we're gonna do a top
ten show that before the end of the year
so I'll give away one of the things
that's been put on the list
colossal oh I [ __ ] love that movie
that's so good the a nice movie yeah yes
aah I mean Anne Hathaway
I went back to the nineties for a second
then half the way move yeah so it's this
really really if you haven't seen it's a
super [ __ ] smart crazy story about
cuz you and apparently this woman who
can control one of the kind you and how
that affects and talks about trauma and
PTSD and responsibilities and all that
stuff in a movie about giant kaiju if
you haven't seen you should see it
because it's beautiful wholly original
it's a movie that like when it's done
you're like I've never seen that before
yeah and and it holds together too
because there's some movies like you can
be like I've never seen that before
and I never will again but this one
you'll want to watch again it's pretty
smart and it takes it does this thing
where it takes turns every like 10-15
minutes that you could not have possibly
foreseen yeah by the previous ten or
fifteen minutes
that was a joyous journey I agree that's
a great pic what about you great me I'm
not barely see anything honestly this
year I've just been working and I would
come home from lose-lose raters doing
things I've never done them before I'd
be really sleepy and I can't I can hide
them I just can't handle the routine and
the world was fine but getting up in the
morning and coming back at the same time
every night and cooking the same then
that's sit in front of a movie and
always fall asleep right but the only
two movies or so that kept me awake last
year okay well yeah word would get out
and a cure for wellness I love that kid
it wasn't Greenville Union but
everything else he's been really
brilliant handed in and are you really
gave it and then took it right away from
that daddy [ __ ] valerian but I loved
him even though he walked his way
through that movie but you know it and
everything else I've seen him he's been
great yeah but that movie but he just
come on and we're every other kid and
movies a super Repton Jack talk he come
on II was just like hanging at the top
of his pants he was a complete physical
wreck through the entire movie and I
thought I thought it looked beautiful if
it stopped like at the end of Act two
it's been one of the greatest horror
movies ever but then of course they say
go for Ben ski ski yeah he was all these
beautiful to tasks so that those were
the ones for me I mean I thought
really obscure picks but this will
actually kick yeah we yeah as well ways
it's just like wow this is great this
little indie movie needs help yeah
exactly
alright that dancers there yeah thank
well done give it up for him great
question wait two more pair of socks
remain ladies and gentlemen means 2
questions JC find us a victim if you
would hey how are you so good it's also
my birthday two days well yeah some
socks Nick what's your star saying nice
astrology sign Sagittarius sorry Thor
yeah just check with with the CW making
you know such great shows like the cross
with the crossover yeah do you guys
would you guys pick to get either its
own show or its also add into this great
you know to be added on to these shows
or anything like that these really
obscure characters I say it over and
over again I they could do them in
movies they can definitely do it on the
CW but I love the character of the
question I wish they can add faceless
the faceless vigilante it could be mix
age could be Renee Montoya I don't give
a [ __ ] but the idea of somebody who
their mask is is featureless that that's
terrifying but I think that could blend
well in that world you folks I would
pick Virgil Hawkins static I mean
they're doing black lightning well and I
have sometimes a couple friends on that
show so I will not say anything bad
about it I've heard actually good things
about it
but I think I think yeah I praise I
won't say bad things about it because I
have worked there I know what guy but I
think I think static there's something
specific about you know like he's he was
supposed to be the spider-man he was
Dwayne McDuffie spider-man and the idea
being able to play with sort of a
teenager in school and high school who's
discovering powers and navigating
friendship and all that [ __ ]
dealing also in the sort of
experience leveled on top of all that
stuff there's a lot of juice to be
squozen from from static that has never
been squozen so yeah what about you sir
I know you probably don't delve deep on
the CW shows I've checked some of them I
mean why I'd love to see you honestly is
the version of the The Guardian I did
Manhattan Guardian and it's just because
it was always a good say op I thought
for a TV show is this guy you know
post-traumatic cop is hired by a
newspaper that's created by the people
for the people to be the superhero
masthead so he starts just investigating
claims he's a superhero reporter and I
just thought it'd be great you did great
procedural Smith that Kaena kind of Jack
Kirby's tale stories like we had the
subway pirates and all that stuff so he
I think would be really good
super grounded kind of thing unless you
know I need them up in the same ones for
last week I can I could use some salt we
got one more pair of socks JC where we
gonna go that's right dark corner how's
it going gentlemen no you these could be
warming your feet any minute awesome
awesome or anything else you want to put
socks the socks don't care I just wanna
say Joe the Barbarian is one of my
famous for as revisiting that universe
is there anything you possible way that
you could do that and in regards to
revisiting do you think the old-school
Image Comics do you think there's any
characters that you can pull out of
there and do something with now I mean
most of the stuff I'm doing no it would
probably be new creator stuff you know
enjoy the Wonder the one thing with
Joy's I always had like three extra
pages not but I'd never got a chance to
put in and I would love to just do them
for some addition because it drives me
nuts every time I read the book I had
this one scene that isn't there but but
know that there's no plans to Reavers
you know again I saamne like to turn
until I got sure and
you know a film or something but as for
the image guys I candidate the ones that
are late you know when I did the world
storm stuff which lasted for like two
months it was the authority and and
Wildcats and I kind of touched on the
characters I liked so I was never I
never a huge fan of each other's are the
kind of artistic poetic snow but that
point in vertigo comics well I give up
applause all right question before we
get out of here a word of thanks to mr.
Morrison not just for coming out and
hanging out with a but a hanging out
with us tonight but more importantly and
I've said it before on the show like
before I went and did whatever I tried
to do before I made Clark's and then
started my creative journey I was I fed
myself on a bountiful meal of things in
pop culture that fueled me for like
literally the last 20 years and I and
and one of them or a lot of it had to do
with grants work and I met somebody last
week who said something very nice to me
they were like thank you for a happy
childhood and I thought that was really
sweet and I thanked I said hey man thank
you for getting me out of that [ __ ]
convenience store so it's mutually
beneficial but not only do I want to
thank you for a happy childhood but a
continued happy adult to it like it's
not even like your best shits behind you
you keep creating better [ __ ] [ __ ]
all the time just like the way you were
talking about those Marvel movies they
learn how to refine each time don't they
you with everything you do you learn how
to refine and get closer to the core of
who you are always loved you as a
storyteller with some of my favorite
characters but you're also like one of
my favorite storytellers in real life I
like just talking so thank you thanks
very much David thanks for having me all
you guys all right
you guys have a good time this evening
any thanks for coming lo thank you for
hanging out with us here on scum and
villainy Cantina in Hollywood we this is
episode 199 199 and episode 200 happens
Thursday and the Chinese Theatre where
we're doing an outdoor show on the
forecourt on the court thereof is
sitting right on the handprints to
benefit the Starlight Children's
Foundation with the folks that line up
what are the folks that line up lining
up lining up that con la I met I knew it
was in the name somewhere so you'd come
out cease I think that all the seats are
spoken for but I think there might be
standing room and stuff like that so
that's gonna be a 200 and then when do
we come back here the 19th so right
before Christmas we'll have one show
we'll do our top tens yes that's a place
to do it
yeah I look forward to it I love doing
this show man I love being in this space
give it up for JC in the bar we got a
great audience a lot of feet faces or
returns I was saying in mark before I
was like we got some norms and some
cliff Clavin Zout they're like people
who are here every time we do the show
and fresh faces all the time who've
braved [ __ ] wildfires in the deep
valley yeah thank you out to the Pope's
adventure and the surrounding areas
who've seen a lot of things just get
burned up recently and whatnot hopefully
there hopefully they're safe and their
loved ones are safe a lot of damage this
one of them yeah bad things about living
out here is so dry oh is that you right
on there dude tweeted about maybe not
being able to come and I was like don't
worry about that you got a lifetime pass
forever but you made it well I take that
[ __ ] pass back then how was it out
there what'd you do
well hold on let JC he'll get you a
microphone so we're not speaking into a
vacuum or come on up here you just speak
that's good I'm glad I'm glad to hear
they made it oh yeah thanks I was
watching my youtube videos last night I
didn't know nothing was going on and I
came out and I saw I could see the fire
on the hill my house for 22 years so you
know it's like panic so I packed up a
bunch of [ __ ] went up the to match and
played my free slot play up there
whatever that didn't last long
no luck there and that I was asked in
the store yeah
I wanted to tweet about the fires and
then I got your tweet and I literally
was like walking out to my car and I
just lost it I just [ __ ] started
weeping in my car you know and then then
all the likes in the comments and stuff
I ended up back in Ventura Walmart
weeping again several hours later and I
was like I'm [ __ ] coming man I'm not
letting some goddamn wildfire like keep
me away cuz I knew my parents were safe
stuff like that I checked on them they
say they were the night stuffing as I
was driving out of town last night I was
late oh my god I'm watching lake like
Hills right about where I work you know
burning and I'm good scare away like we
get to see it from a distance here and
it's still front yeah imagine what it's
like when you get close we've seen
harrowing pictures and I'm jelly in
times of cars escaping flame right I'm
just like everybody else you know I've
seen the disasters but I've never been
in a middle of one it's just like can I
put some things and you know check or
whatever like what you know prior to
priorities it does whether or not you
want to yeah it's like I've been waiting
for this like I saw you in 2001 for Jay
and Bob strike back I went to the
comic-con for the first and only time
because it got too much it's too crazy
now like I feel like yeah that's very
good you know to try to get in the Hall
H be impossible but I think that's where
you were I wait I waited in line for
and to but I had a blast and then I was
like when you guys start doing this I
was like no [ __ ] you know like it's fine
this year
yeah way smaller room you could throw a
tissue at us yeah like please don't I
don't want to know what's in the tissues
you guys sell out so fast I like was
waiting for payday and I snot I decided
to check and I saw there was a shirt and
I was like oh [ __ ] I need to borrow some
money his leg I can't miss out you know
I'm gonna miss every show if I wait til
my check has yeah so I did that and Here
I am and then last night I was like oh
yeah just my [ __ ] look like the
world's gonna start burning be kidding
when I'm about to go see you know gonna
have fun cuz I haven't done yeah I
haven't gone out a lot of sense Mike
seven years ago this is like the best
country song where's dad and mom and dad
are safe yeah mom and dad are cool and
my brother's also with that we were both
staying there helping them sell their
house so that's nice - ha your house
burns down right before their yeah
they're in the middle of a deal right
now and you know also a couple of weeks
before people buy and are like hold one
charge like a hundred thousand more cuz
it's the only house left yeah yeah but
anyways thank you for that you know and
of course everything else like I found
you in a video store when Dogma was
released and a day off I went home I was
like oh yeah I remember seeing a trailer
for this during Christmas I came back
here and I went back to Oregon where I
was living and I was like immediately
like I was like this guy like he gets it
you're like I don't know there was
something about it I was like I I lost
it a long time ago but back then I
really got come on you're too humble man
you created the shared universe you
pioneered it in the stove
I mean you were saying John Hughes and
stuff like that but that you know I
don't think he's ever had characters
crossover like that you know you you're
about today online the John Hughes
they didn't cross over but all the
Hughes movies most of them rat took
place in Shermer Illinois or reference
Shermer Illinois that's where I got the
idea I was like oh like [ __ ] I remember
seeing weird science and I was like hi
holy [ __ ] they said Shermer Illinois and
that's where they served attention in
The Breakfast Club and of course comic
books like everyone shared the universe
and comic books so I brought it over
from there and also a little unsung
cameo in coming to America when they cut
to Don Ameche
and Ralph Bellamy like John Landis did
it years ago just a seasonally they're
walking through the park and they give
money to two bums and all sudden it's
the two guys that Eddie Murphy beat in
Trading Places and I remember being in
the theatre a bit like Holly [ __ ] it's
kind of a sea wall like so I remember
what I wanted when I was making my
flicks I was like well it's time
together because that was fun when I saw
that so I got to give a credit for those
that went before me you showed a
seven-year-old dog Deadpool even makes
more sense than Dogma though to be fair
what did he make a dog me he's like I
like the poop monster the angel movie as
my mother calls it as well and not
because the angels in it she's like my
angel made it she likes me a lot smart
don't let him see the end yeah it's kind
of frightening I'm right on well well
you made it through the rain over the
fire in this case put it together for
him ladies and gentlemen
all right and I guess that's all the
show we got for you thanks for being
here with us come hell or high water and
thanks again to Grant Morrison for being
our guests for coming along guys mr.
mark barnard you for always providing
the intelligence to the show give it up
for mark ladies jumping song and that is
Batman I'm back for it Batman for this
week I'm Kevin Smith I'm Marvin Arden
and who are you tune in next time same
fad time same fat channel SModcast calm
or youtube.com slash Kevin Smith good
night everybody
you